Vsauce Kevin here with 17.3 percent and
you think you know what that means
because numbers are clear and objective
it's 17.3 percent but maybe it's been
17.3 for a while because you focused on
getting 31.3 over here down to the low
20s instead maybe 17.3 is lower than the
average of 21.8 but it was 17.4 last
year so you've made virtually no
statistical progress in 12 months maybe
what you're measuring spiked for a few
days just last week so your 17.3 is a
98.85 increase over the 8.7 it was last
Monday your problem just basically
doubled maybe your job depends on what
these numbers actually mean and how you
can influence them in your favor and
maybe a number that makes us look safer
actually means we're less safe
17.3 percent means policing may be less
about protect and serve and more about
perverse incentives the fact that a
number can mean everything and nothing
suggests that police departments are
gamifying crime you just don't know it
compstat is short for either computer
statistics or comparative statistics no
one can actually remember and to
understand comstat you need to
understand the New York City of the
1970s and 80s New York was an Infamous
hotbed of crime including violent crime
so much so that movies like death wish
the Warriors and Taxi Driver expressed
the fear of New Yorkers and enthralled
everyone else Serpico detailed the
real-life Corruption of New York's own
police force and the Son of Sam murders
made every single New Yorker realize how
vulnerable they really were by the 1980s
New York City was a pretty scary place
my earliest personal memory of it was my
grandma making my cousin remove and hide
her jewelry on a visit to the Statue of
Liberty Rudy Giuliani was elected mayor
in 1993 to be tough on crime and he
appointed had built Bratton as chief of
police Breton had served as chief of the
New York City Transit Police who had
begun using a crime tracking system
developed by Jack Maple it was as simple
and basic as you can get they recorded
and mapped crimes on the transit system
manually because they weren't doing it
at all before New York City's crime
statistics were really only collected
for the purpose of reporting them to the
FBI and that meant no actionable
real-time information and the only data
they did have was a year old 20 years
after we put a man on the moon there
still wasn't a database that recorded
the time your aunt Ethel got her purse
snatched walking home from Bingo the
solution was compstat which started in
1994 when the department realized there
was way too much crime to track manually
with push pins so they bought a single
computer from Radio Shack comstat works
like this every week New York City's 98
police precinct service areas and
Transit districts report detailed
statistics about all their activity
crime reports arrests summonses and
tickets as well as updates on ongoing
investigations and changes in crime
patterns that information is loaded into
a city-wide database that generates
comstat reports with specific statistics
and their weekly monthly and annual
changes over time like maybe muggings
are up 14 month to month in Bayside
Queens while they're down eight percent
city-wide Bayside might have a problem
maybe the week to week New York City
homicide rate is unchanged at zero
percent that's bad but it's down 83.3
percent compared to 1993. that's good
compstat is a sensible way to keep track
of threats to Public Safety and inform
how best to respond to them and the data
is only the beginning of the comstat
initiative it's meant to inform
effective tactics rapid deployment of
resources and Relentless follow-up it
drives the daily operations of police
forces in most major cities and its
proponents tout its homegrown Origins
its efficient and accurate
community-based implementation and its
innovative and pivotal role in public
safety but its critics say it fuels
harassment and ignores the most serious
crimes two hundred thirteen thousand one
hundred sixty that's the average number
of hours you're going to spend in your
lifetime sleeping that's
24.33 years of mattress time so why do
that on an old clunker Helix sleep the
sponsor of this video makes premium
mattresses and bedding customized to fit
your needs and shipped to your door
simply take their sleep quiz it matched
me with the sunset Lux because I'm a
side sleep who likes a soft mattress and
share a bed with my wife I've had this
mattress for three months now and it is
unbelievably comfortable we're sleeping
great and it was easy to order online
with your Helix Sleep mattress you get a
100 night sleep trial along with a
10-year warranty and there are financing
options and flexible payment plans and
the mattress delivers right to your door
for free within the US click on the link
below or go to helixsleep.com
vsauce2 for up to 200 off your Helix
Sleep mattress plus two free pillows
criminologist George Kelling was hired
by New York City in 1985 after writing
the book fixing broken windows which
jump started A Simple Theory of policing
aggressively rained in really low level
highly visible crimes like jaywalking
and vandalism and you reduce the public
perception of disorder and a drop in
real crime will follow
comstat fit perfectly with the broken
windows Theory because all of that stuff
is easily tracked and quantifiable the
problem is you get more of what you
measure weekly comstat meetings resulted
in pressure for precincts to bring down
numbers and that incentivizes two things
one focusing on what can be measured
easily and the raw reduction of
statistical outputs want to play good
cop bad cop it's time to play good cop
bad cop good cop solves a burglary which
has a negligible impact on the comstat
report bad cop issues 20 tickets for
jaywalking that reaches a Target quota
and proves police are doing something
good cop deals with open container
violations he comes across when they're
a clear and public problem bad cop
intentionally seeks them out to improve
Monday today's numbers then deliberately
switches Focus to another minor crime
after the comstat meeting told him to
good cops patrols and community
relations efforts have kept crime
numbers low but they've plateaued it's
probably the best they'll ever be since
crime is never going to be zero bad cop
makes as many arrests as he can to drive
numbers down by whatever means necessary
good cop classifies crimes based on the
evidence bad cop focuses on just the
evidence that will classify a crime in
the category he needs the right numbers
in sometimes that means upgrading or
downgrading charges so like whether a
perpetrator is charged with sexual abuse
in the fourth degree or forcible
touching on a Thursday might depend on a
number from a meeting on Monday so
between good cop and bad cop which cop
is likely to get get promoted
according to the numbers bad cops
quantitative results make the case he's
a more effective policeman but the good
cop is a good cop and the math makes his
Public Service invisible
statistical performance matters and it
could create a conflict between good
policing and good compstat but how well
can we even use arrest data to isolate
the true causes of crime in a city
what's a normal fluctuation did New York
City's crime rate go down because of
comstat or did life just get better
overall comstat offers a glimpse at
patterns of criminal activity
neighborhood and city-wide but it also
encourages constant pressure to generate
great statistics
even when it's not really possible
comstats seemed to work right out of the
gate in a year murders were down 20
percent and felonies on public transit
were down about 30 percent Jack Maple
whose autobiography is titled the crime
fighter putting the bad guys out of
business died in 2001. now Los Angeles
and New York and Boston and Washington
DC are all using forms of compstat and
smaller police forces are two we've
experienced 30 years of comstat
including both Rises and drops in crime
more transparency with policing data
criticism of random stop and frisk
policies and more questions than when
the program started but we've also
gamified Public Safety
we've kind of turned policing into
Pokemon
and at this point it isn't entirely
clear whether we're catching real people
or catching arbitrary numbers
gotta catch them all though
right
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]